Good Morning Hank, it's Tuesday.
Today I'll be reviewing the mobile version of the famous board game Monopoly.
I hadn't played Monopoly in a number of years before downloading the app, and
what I'd forgotten (or maybe just never noticed)
is that Monopoly is a terrible game.
The basic idea you buy property and then charge rent when your opponent lands on that property
leads to a game that is distressingly similar to real contemporary human life.
Monopoly unfolds slowly at first and very quickly at the end,
people find meanings in its outcomes even though it's mostly random,
and it's only occasionally fun.
The mobile game brings all the terrible things about Monopoly
to your phone, while adding some new additional terrible things.
Consider for instance Rich Uncle Penny Bags,
who plays a minor role in the board game
but here shows up to introduce
you to Monopoly EVERY SINGLE TIME YOU PLAY.
Also, since you can't play online with friends or
enemies, you're forced to play against a not
particularly intelligent Artificial Intelligence.
And when the AI begins to lose, it quickly becomes desperate,
proposing on each turn increasingly ludicrous trades
in an attempt to acquire properties, and you have to
decline these trades over and over, and after a while
you start to feel guilty because the ONLY thing
this Artificial Intelligence has been told to do is
win at Monopoly, and so now it's failing at
literally its only goal, whereas
you, a thinking feeling human, have a variety of
passions and fulfillments outside this mobile game
so sometimes you just end up agreeing to the ridiculous trades
to make the AI happy, even so, you usually win eventually.
but you can't even enjoy it properly because
you feel so sorry for the sad little Artificial Intelligence kitten.
Or maybe that's just me.
Anyway, by far the worst thing about Monopoly,
both the board game and the mobile app, is its
convoluted self-contradictory analysis of capitalism.
Like, the game is essentially about how acquiring
land and the ability to exploit monopolies is literally
a roll of the dice,
and yet the game also celebrates getting rich.
I mean the only way to win is to bankrupt your opponents,
and this turns out to be partly a product of Monopoly's
complicated origin story. So in 1935 a door-to-door salesman
named Charles Darrow sold his board game Monopoly
to the company Parker Brothers.
The game became a hugely successful; Darrow was the
first board game millionaire,
and his story embodied the American Dream, a rags
to riches tale of an american inventor who became successful
via his individual genius and hard work.
Today there's a plaque celebrating Darrow on the boardwalk
at Atlantic City, and Parker Brothers often prints his
heroic story alongside the game's instructions.
There's just one problem, which is that Charles Darrow
did not invent Monopoly.
30 years earlier, a woman named Elizabeth Magie
invented a board game called The Landlord's Game,
and although it was in many ways similar
to the Monopoly we play today, it was a more direct
attack on land monopolism and an exploration of how over time,
capital tends to become concentrated in fewer and fewer hands.
She patented the game, and even tried to sell it to Parker Brothers,
but they passed. Still, the Landlord's game became popular
in progressive circles and was even used as a teaching tool
at the University of Pennsylvania's Wharton Finance school.
For decades, many people played the game and
changed the rules as they went. Along the way, some
versions of it came to be called Monopoly, and then in
1933, Charles Darrow played Monopoly at a friend's house
and afterwards, asked for a written version of the rules.
He altered some of the design, patented the game, and became a millionaire.
And so the story we hear of an individual
rightly rewarded for his genius, turns out to be a far more complicated
story of a woman who invented a game that thousands of
collaborators then improved by playing it.
A story of capitalism working, turns out to be a story of capitalism failing.
I mean, the game that became so popular was really created
by a community,  and the free market failed to reward that
community, instead wrongly assigning most of the value to one contributor who,
truthfully, added very little to the game. This iPhone app,
by the way, is published by Hasbro, the multi-national
conglomerate that now owns the very same
Parker Brothers company that declined Elizabeth Magie's game,
only to later buy Charles Darrow's version.
Of course, none of this answers the underlying question,
which is how anyone ever enjoyed Monopoly in the first place.
(I guess maybe  Settlers of Catan hadn't been invented yet.)
Regardless, the history of Monopoly turns out
to be a far more interesting study of capitalism than the
boring game itself. (I give it 2 out of 10, not recommended.)
Hank, I'll see you on Friday.